[Music]
everyone Peter from GameSpot Tony from
GameSpot universe and we just found out
like maybe you have that Castlevania is
getting a TV show coming to Netflix and
there's some pretty interesting people
behind this project even though it's an
unexpected turn of events yeah so we
there's not a whole lot of information
known but Warren Ellis is one of the
executive producers he read comics
that's a big name I mean he's he's done
trans trans metropolitan he's done some
x-men stuff he's written James Bond he's
he's done a bunch of stuff he's a really
good writer so that adds a lot of
credibility there that yeah this is
going to be legit it's going to be it's
not going to be like a fluff piece sure
and we know it's also going to be an
animated series and the studio's I guess
the team behind that also has a lot of
experience with shows like Adventure
Time and Fairly OddParents you were
telling me a little bit about Frederator
Studios which is where this being made
yeah so Frederator I believe they it's a
platform for creators to put their
launch through projects so that
Adventure Time and and bravest warriors
are to kind of have a similar tone
similar styles because that makes me
wonder is Castlevania gonna be like
Adventure Time right
even though asposed to be a dark
medieval fantasy so that would truly
just think no it's gonna be more serious
but obvious NCAR who produced that sort
of like gritty power rangers short he's
involved with this right yeah he produce
a dread oh yeah so yeah yeah so he's
he's legit maybe it'll be a nice balance
of the two
yeah awesome that could be he also did
two gray with Liam Neeson oh yeah thanks
Arnett yeah I think he was like one of
the youngest producers to do really good
huh it's fascinating um but so how it
could this relate to the game series uh
well what we do know it's going to
incorporate the last surviving Belmont
which based on the games is Julius
Belmont it was born in 1980 the last
game we saw him in was bleep aria of
sorrow or dawn of sorrow and that took
place in 2035 but we also know
specifically he's fighting vlad dracula
Teppei so dracula as we know him not
some weird resurrected version of him
the last instance of dracula in the game
series was in 1999 within the story of
the game and he was sealed away in a
solar eclipse and i have no i
you know what that means but apparently
in the game world that meant that he's
gone for good so potentially this will
start Julius Belmont in his teenage
years fighting Dracula before the turn
of the millennium yeah unless unless or
like let's introduce some young goofy
kid sure but I they can't do that it's
hard to know I mean people really care
about this series on the gaming side of
things but there's gonna be a Netflix is
made by it's got people behind I'm sure
it's gonna be trying to hit the broadest
audience possible so they could do
anything they want really yeah so that
that'll be the interesting thing to see
what what does our art look like you
know what are the character models again
is it going to be Adventure Time or is
it going to be yeah it's gonna be three
two your 2d right yeah yeah so much
stuff we don't know yeah we don't know a
lot but as stories develop and as we
learn more stay tuned a game spot for
game details and games by universe for
more on entertainment and Netflix in
general you know what would be
interesting for this one with a vlad
dracula Teppei what if they got his
cousin vlad dracula pepe no let us know
what you think which is your favorite
Castlevania game put in the comments
below and subscribe please